did the Kardashians just hit at Khloe's
pregnancy also what Justin Bieber's
family really thinks of selena happy
hump day my people there are 17 days
left of 2017 and you know what still
hasn't happened yet the Kardashians have
yet to confirm that Khloe and Kylie are
pregnant what's the deal my money was on
the Kardashians 25 days of Christmas
card they've been sharing a photo of day
and I thought the last batch would be of
the prego sisters but today Chloe
appeared in one and didn't have a baby
bump Kim told us that they shot the card
on November 7th and of course we learned
Chloe was pregnant in September but I'm
still very confused perhaps they are
waiting to make the announcement on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians and by
they I mean Kris Jenner because the
reality show may have hinted at Khloe's
pregnancy and a new promo and in it the
family appears to be gathered together
as they receive some big news
like I mentioned et learned Coco was
pregnant with a boy in September just
days after a source confirmed us Kylie
was expecting a girl with Travis Scott
again no one has gone on the record
about this but momager Kris did give
fans a clue about her family expanding
on a holiday episode of their show is to
pray that one of you guys would have a
baby and now it's like a faucet that we
turned on children it's bad
to watch your kids because it's truly
just left so time will only tell folks
but you know what is certain Justin
Bieber and Selena Gomez are going strong
though on-again off-again couple are
definitely on again and Selena just got
a big blessing from Justin's family
while the two have yet to confirm their
relationship status a source tells ET
Justin's family thinks she is the good
influence he needs quote Selena is 100%
the reason Justin turned his life around
he knows he's lucky to have this second
chance and he's not taking it for
granted the source adds that his 180
hasn't been hard though he wants to
change quote he knows what's at stake he
would way rather spend a quiet night in
with Selena then go get wasted and hook
up with random girls that lifestyle just
doesn't appeal to him anymore
as for Justin's mom Patti well
apparently she's always had a soft spot
for Selena
meanwhile music was on the minds of the
Bellas last night the cast of pitch
perfect three celebrated the third film
in the franchise at the LA premiere et's
Carly still got the ladies to give us
their favorite celebrity impressions and
it was pretty damn fun if you want to
sing a couple of bars of a song that sum
up the epic scale of this premiere what
would it be
what's the song about massive I like big
butts and I cannot lie
this is crazy down Hollywood Boulevard
[Music]
in Stuart which I've done to her and
she's like yeah um I just um I don't man
I am and you know I don't know it's not
even now it'll be real fun to see them
all together again when pitch-perfect 3
hits theaters on December 22nd all right
guys give us a thumbs up if you like it
out and as always be kind rewind wait
that's not right I meant like and share
this video that's right and be sure to
subscribe to our Channel we've got some
fun end-of-the-year videos coming your
way very very soon so I'll see you guys
smile
[Music]